cuando comienzas a aprender matemáticas
ves cosas como 2 3
esto es igual a 5 o puedes ver cosas
como por ejemplo 6 + 1
esto es igual a 7 o tal vez las cosas
con resta por ejemplo puedes llegar a tu
parte con cosas como como 8 menos 2 es
igual a 6 y en todos estos casos tal vez
tú piensas que el signo igual te pide la
respuesta es decir que averigües cuánto
es 2 + 3 bueno pues la respuesta es 5 o
que averigües la respuesta de cuánto es
6 + 1 a bueno pues es 7 o por ejemplo 8
menos 2 de respuesta 6 pero eso no está
del todo bien lo que el signo igual dice
es que lo que está del lado izquierdo de
la ecuación es la misma cantidad que la
del lado derecho de la ecuación nos dice
que qué 2 + 3 es lo mismo que 5
y no tenías que escribirlo así puedes
por ejemplo escribir que 5 es igual a 2
+ 3 o puedes escribir que 323 más 2 esto
es lo mismo que dos más 3 ahora nota que
aquí no estamos averiguando la respuesta
sólo estamos diciendo que lo que lo que
sea tres más dos es lo mismo que lo que
es dos más tres sabemos que ambos son
igual a 5 ahora también puedes por
ejemplo mezclar suma y resta puedes
escribir cosas del estilo por ejemplo 6
+ 1
esto es lo mismo esto es igual a 8 menos
a seis más uno es igual a 8 menos uno
son la misma cantidad seis más uno
cuánto es ese 7 y 8 menos 1 cuánto es
eso es 7 también entonces el signo igual
no significa dame la respuesta o suma
estos dos números o resta los el signo
igual lo que quiere decir es que lo que
esté del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
es lo mismo que lo que está del lado
derecho de la ecuación y ya con esto en
mente vamos a escribir algunos algunas
ecuaciones algunos argumentos usando el
signo igual y averigüemos cuáles de
ellos son verdaderos y cuáles son falsos
entonces hagamos eso muy bien si yo
escribo por ejemplo esto
voy a escribir esto no voy a decir que
es porque tal vez esté tal vez sobre la
respuesta entonces esto es verdadero
bueno veamos el número del lado
izquierdo es 18 y el número del lado
derecho es un número diferente es 81 lo
que hicimos fue cambiar el orden del 1 y
el 8 entonces bueno este este es un
número distinto es este un número 381
así que estos números 18 y 81 no son
iguales
estos no son iguales y en ocasiones
verás una raya cruzando el signo igual
eso significa que no son iguales o que
son distintos 18 no es igual a 81 ahora
sigamos qué pasaría si yo escribo y
escribo 9 menos 3 + 2 - 0
igual a
digamos 0 + 1
- 1
+ 8 esto es verdad bueno vamos a
averiguar esto qué cantidad tenemos del
lado izquierdo
9 - 13 6 + 2 es 8 -0 es igual a 8 así
que el lado izquierdo este lado esto es
igual a 8 ahora veamos que tenemos del
lado derecho
tenemos 0 + 1 menos uno bueno más uno
menos uno es igual a cero entonces
tenemos simplemente 8 por lo tanto esto
sí es verdadero 8 es igual a 8 ajá esto
simplemente es otra manera de escribir
89 menos tres más dos menos cero eso es
igual a ocho y también el lado derecho
es ocho entonces el signo igual lo que
nos dice es que del lado izquierdo
tendremos la misma cantidad que del lado
derecho
hagamos otros dos ejemplos digamos que
yo tengo esto esto es verdadero bueno
pues tal vez tú pienses que si yo pongo
un 1 y un 0 juntos eso será un 10
10 es igual a 1 entonces estamos
diciendo que 10 es igual a 1 eso es
falso cierto entonces eso es distinto y
también esto es distinto 10 no es igual
a 1 hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que yo
tengo siete más uno igual a 34
este argumento es verdadero bueno siete
más uno es igual a 8 y 3 más 4 es igual
a 7 entonces 8 es distinto de 7 estos no
son iguales y terminamos